yellow coming out I feel Vindicated
again seven out of the eight charges
have been upheld and most importantly
the one institutional racism at
Yorkshire County Fair Club has been
proven uh I know the people
um you know get hung up on one stuff but
for me from the offset I've been very
clear that this is not about uh
individuals and it's very much about the
wider game
um Michael Vaughn has put out a long
statement on social media about this and
I just want to put some of the the
points that he um he wrote to you he
said that CDC proceedings were an
inappropriate inadequate and backward
step particularly with an issue is this
yeah I mean look we never know what the
right way to deal with this stuff was or
is uh it was never going to be
um you know a clear path but it became
evident that for the game to start
really
um accepting what had happened
um uh things would have to be uh you
know dealt with and there would have to
be uh under you know independent panel
um you know we will never know whether
it was the right thing or not but I
think it's really important that at this
stage now that everyone really reflects
um accepts that the game is not
um done anywhere near enough and you
know comes together because the reason
for me speaking out was for the game to
get better for my kids and everyone
else's and at this stage if people don't
come together I think that'll be
difficult to happen let's talk about
that wider reflection terrific because
you yourself
um had to confront your own
anti-Semitism in all of this didn't you
no one comes out looking particularly
good
yeah look I you know when that came
forward uh I did exactly what I asked
anyone else to do I accepted it
apologize but you know I I felt like I
went further and you know it was
important you know there's always going
to be you know people might not ever
forgive me for that and that's
understandable but from my point of view
I you know I apologized
um and I've tried to really understand
more about the Jewish Community from it
I'll go back now to Michael Vaughn's
statement and he does mention you in it
quite extensively and he said we had
what I thought was a really positive and
constructive discussion we shook hands
with the shared intention to work
together in order to create positive
change in cricket for my part nothing
has altered in that respect
is that what you're going to do now work
for positive change in cricket has there
been any positive change in qriket and
if not what are you going to do about it
yeah look from my point of view I've
always been uh from right from the
offset I've been trying to get people to
get in a room and really uh start to
have conversations with each other
because I think that is the way forward
um and I'm I'm always open to that look
this morning has been a bit of a you
know I need to understand the findings
and digest what's happened and you know
heal a little bit myself as well it's
been a tough uh tough two and a half
years uh and I face the brunt of it but
it's really important now that um you
know that there's a real willingness
from everyone to make cricket you know
the game that we all love
um what it should be
um azim I'm just going to read something
that's just come in if you stay with us
for a moment this is Richard Thompson
the ECB chair has said this he said this
has been an incredibly challenging
period for our sport but one we must all
learn from in order to make cricket
better and more inclusive when azim
Rafiq spoke out about his time in qriket
he exposed a side of our game which no
one should have had to experience we are
grateful for his courage and
perseverance and given the nature of
these cases they've taken a clear toll
on everyone involved there now needs to
be a time of reconciliation where as a
game we can collectively learn and heal
the wounds and ensure that nothing like
this can ever happen again that's from
Richard Thompson the ECB chair what's
your reaction to that
yeah look you know like I said for me
it's very much a moment now after
everything that's happened over the last
three years it's a moment for everyone
to make a decision you know are we going
to make cricket better or is there going
to be you know because let's not be
around a bush at the minute you know
there is a large part of the qriket
community that is very hesitant and
resistance to change hence why we've not
moved forward uh but you know everyone's
got a decision to make it we all have to
take responsibility because the one
thing that unites us all is the game
that we all love and you know
um you know it kills me I've lost so
much love uh of the game that's given me
so much good times as well and you know
I just hope in the future at some point
um you know that love can come back
you're testing me in front of the select
committee it was very difficult to read
difficult to hear I knew you said you
yourself have said that racism cost you
your career
does the ruling today bring you any sort
of Peace does it bring you any sort of
closure in order for you to move forward
in the way you say that everyone in the
game needs to do
yeah look I'm in the hearing a couple of
weeks ago I felt like some sort of
closure
um you know I've been pushed to the
absolute limits
um you know
it's been you know I've been very clear
of not making it about individuals but
you know the only time this has become
about individuals is when certain
sections of um you know try to uh go
after me in a huge manner but I I just
you know like I said the hearing for me
was some uh closure and I just want now
uh for my family to get some healing
time
um you know it's been it's been tough
um for us all and I just hope that now
the game and sections of the game can
really start to
um come together because you know if the
game doesn't then there was absolutely
no point in
um me and my family and everyone else
going through what we have
can the game continue
if those sections are still there
yes absolutely I think from for me you
can't have a situation where you just uh
you have one side and the other there's
got to be understanding and
conversations and um to move forward uh
look they're gonna have to accept it and
I hope what the hearing did do if
nothing else is send a clear message to
anyone involved in qriket that
um you know this is not acceptable and
it will be Zero Tolerance moving forward
um so look it's a decision for everyone
to make individually but as a game to
make collectively as well